so my wife was at a town hall last week
for the entire week and she came back on
Saturday you know there's that whole
stereotype that men are incompetent
parents who don't know how to function
and can't take care of their own kids
especially if the wife isn't around I'm
proud to say that that's not me and in
my experience that's not how most men
are you know we can take care of our
kids perfectly capable but as a dad you
know I just do things a little bit
differently that's all it's a difference
in in approach really is the difference
like for instance the day before she got
back I realized that I had not bathed
the kids all week you know which was
just it was an oversight I just I didn't
think I guess my sense of smell isn't
quite up to par with my wife especially
because she's pregnant now so I just
didn't I didn't sense it they had been
bathe bathed and so then I realized that
they needed to be mainly because my
daughter said to me hey we haven't taken
a bath in a week dad what's going on and
so what I decided to do was rather than
what my wife will do she'll give them
each a bath separately and there's this
whole long it takes like two hours to go
through all the bath well I thought I
don't have time for that
so I just lathered them down with Dawn
dish soap and I had him run through the
sprinkler and and they came out smelling
like just washed plates right out of the
dishwasher it was great and they had fun
it required no effort on my part took
ten minutes and it's all about
efficiency really that's the main thing
I think with dads we are we are very
efficient whereas we know we're not
gonna win points for style like like
women will with their parenting but we
still we get the job done is the point
at the end of the day the job is done
and and everyone goes home happy all
right so there's a very a couple
interesting stories I want to talk about
today but before we do let's talk about
finding freelance talent for your
business or project finding the right
freelancer can be time-consuming even
more than giving kids Bad's it's a very
time-consuming frustrating expensive
process
where do you find the talent how much is
it gonna cost how can you be certain
that they're going to deliver for you
thanks to fiber finding the right
freelancer doesn't have to be a struggle
I've talked to plenty of people who have
used this service and the thing that
they always talk about the word that
keeps coming up is simple it just makes
the search for freelancer so much
simpler than it otherwise would be it's
very just convenient simple process
fibers marketplace connects businesses
with freelancers who offer hundreds of
digital services including graphic
design copywriting web programming film
editing and much more find what you're
looking for instantly search by service
delivery time price reviews whatever you
want to do you however you want to
customize it that's how you can go about
finding it there are no surprises you'll
know exactly what you're paying for
upfront no negotiating needed take five
and check out Fiverr calm you'll receive
10% off your first order by using my
code Walsh it's so easy don't waste any
more time get the service you deserve by
going to fiverr.com F IV e
don't forget the extra are.com code
Walsh again that's fiverr.com code Walsh
okay now let's talk about the saga of
Erika Thomas The Ballad of Erika Thomas
maybe we should say Jesse Thomas Erika
Smollett pick a name Erika Thomas is a
state representative in Georgia Democrat
of course black woman she claimed over
the weekend that she was accosted
verbally assaulted by a racist white man
at the grocery store and she says she
was in the express lane she had too many
items which she admits and her reason
for this is as she says she's nine
months pregnant I'm not sure how being
nine months pregnant means that you have
to be in the express lane but that's
what she says never mind that for now so
she says the guy came up to her white
guy and said you lazy son of a B go back
where you came from because she had too
many items in the self-check or the
express lane she recorded a video so
we're gonna go there's a couple video
clips we're gonna play here as we follow
this story
and watch it you know come to its climax
and its conclusion it's just it's of
it's kind of a three-act play here we've
got so here's the first act she she
recorded a video a live stream talking
about this incident very emotional she's
in tears watch this I decided to go live
because I'm very upset because people
are getting really out of control with
this with this white privilige stuff I'm
at the grocery store and I'm in the tent
out the Audi says ten items or less yes
I have 15 items but I'm not most
pregnant and I can't stand up for lo his
white man comes up to me and says you
lazy son of a [ __ ] you need to go back
where you came from you don't even know
me up that lazy oh that must pregnant
this is you're ignorant
okay now I'm look I'm no prophet I am a
no seer of the future but I saw that
video on Saturday morning or whatever it
was and I immediately knew that that the
story is not exactly as she's telling it
my BS radar was just blaring I could
almost hear it in my ears much probably
get that checked out actually by a
neurologist but I just it was it was
going off big-time watching that video I
mean even if it was even if it did
happen the way she says it did even if
it was totally true collapsing into
tears on live stream is completely phony
and contrived so at a minimum you know
that her reaction is phony at a minimum
whatever happened to people having
disagreements you
you have run-ins heated exchanges with
strangers and then just then you you
continue about your day whatever
happened to that is nobody capable of
that anymore why do you need to tell
everybody why are you sobbing about it
like a child I mean I've had words with
strangers in public before it might
surprise you to learn I've I've had
conflicts before with people sometimes
over stuff like this the the minutiae of
daily life and I I don't go home and
just collapse it oh my god she was so
mean to me I don't do that I've never
done it um you just you you're an adult
you go about your day but regardless it
was obvious to me that at a minimum
she's not telling the whole story you
know if your BS detector isn't going off
watching that then you do you must not
have a BS detector you're you're the
kind of person who you must be the only
way you could fall for that is if you're
the kind of person who gets an email
from a Nigerian prince telling you that
you've uh that you're gonna inherit ten
million dollars if you only send your
social security number in your bank
account information and and and you
actually and you go Elektra my dough you
my life is has been changed for the
better you have to be that level of
gullible to fall for what you just saw
there because the story doesn't make
sense first of all she's in the wrong
checkout line and the guy comes up and
says hey go back where you came from
even from the logic even even from the
perspective of a racist it just kind of
trying to see things with racist logic
for a minute even from that perspective
it doesn't make sense even as a racist
it doesn't make sense the whole idea
that a racist guy would conveniently use
that phrase in that context the phrase
which has been the discussion this is
the subject of so much discussion this
week and he just so happens to come up
and use it for no apparent reason to a
Democrat lawmaker come on this seems
just like smollett it seems just like
Smollett because it is a Democrats idea
of what
Republican racist sounds like this is
someone who this is their fantasy of
what a of what a racist and counter
would be like in their fantasies
Republicans are the kind of people who
just run around screaming go back where
you came from this is magnet country to
random strangers for no reason but
despite the lack of believability here
still the left seized on her story the
the media reported it amplified it
uncritically we've done this over and
over again we did it was some Alette we
did it with covington over and over
again we see this there's there's
there's no no questions are asked it's
just out she said it happened so it
happened i hash tag I stand with Erika
trended on Twitter which sidebar for a
minute can we all can we stop standing
with people I mean can we have one week
on social media where there isn't a
hashtag I stand with whoever today ever
every other day we're all standing with
somebody what do you what does it even
mean we stand with them I what does that
mean you're you sent a hashtag when you
stand with them there's no there's no
doesn't mean anything in the first place
I I stayed with Ana Erika Democrats
blamed it on Trump this is Trump's
America etc etc etc well this is where
things get interesting Thomas
Erica Thomas went back to the store
where this hate crime had occurred
allegedly to be interviewed by reporters
remember she's nine months pregnant and
she can't stand and that's why she was
in the express lane but she can stand
out in the heat in the parking lot and
talk to reporters she could do that so
you put a camera in front of her flat
face she could stand all day but no she
couldn't stand for you know a couple of
minutes in the regular checkout line in
the air-conditioning couldn't do that so
she goes back to talk about it and while
she is giving her telling her tale doing
her whole routine the guy the alleged
racist shows up at the parking lot and
confronts her and already you know look
look if this actually happened and this
guy really you know
a racist and is being exposed there is
no way he shows up to be on to put his
face on camera to you know to announce
that he was the guide if this is
actually true there's no way the guy
shows up so the very fact that he even
showed up already tells you that okay
you know if your if your BS detector was
going off you were right he shows up he
accuses her of lying and here's the
local media reporters here's watch how
this all unfolds I'm a lie about what
everything that happened do you feel bad
me telling you to go back where you came
from you see did I say that yes you
seriously you think I say it on video
did you say to me I called you a lazy
people
okay that's the worst thing I said
that's all you said to me yes okay
because that makes you look better
because everybody's after you now so
that makes you look better to say that I
know what I said she's doing it for
political purposes period like I said
earlier I'm a Democrat I will vote
Democrat the rest of my life okay so to
call me what she wants to believe for
her political purposes to make it black
white brown or whatever it's so untrue
he needs to be held accountable because
people can't just go out in public areas
and berate pregnant women whether it's
because I was pregnant whether it was
because I was black okay so this guy is
a Democrat he's a piece of digital life
long time says he's gonna continue being
a Democrat he's a Cuban too he said he's
Cuban I don't they didn't they didn't I
don't think they show that in that
report but he said he was Cuban he's a
Democrat he admits that he called her
the B word but he says the rest never
happened then you see that moment where
they're looking each other in the eyes
and he's saying to her you know this
didn't happen and you right there in
that moment if if you can if you are
able to detect liars you you can tell
right there from that exchange
she knows she's lying but what it
appears is here's the interesting thing
he admits that he called her the B word
so he admits that he called a pregnant
woman the B word and
so Thomas made a classic blunder she
played the wrong victim card okay so in
the in the victim game she played the
wrong card she could have cried over
sexism that's how she should have framed
this if she had just said that this was
sexism that she was attacked accosted
verbally assaulted by a by a by a sexist
toxically masculine you know misogynist
then I think she takes the win here she
wins
because the guy said it now I'm not
saying that he's actually sexist for
calling of the b-word I'm also not
saying that's a appropriate language to
use but it sounds like she was being a
jerk she was in the wrong check-out line
he came up to her confronted sounds like
there was some kind of exchange they
were gone back and forth they were
hurling things she said some things she
said something that's what it sounds
like so it doesn't make him a sexist but
my point is she could have played that
card that would have been the smarter
card to play because he did say the word
and that's all that really as far as
society is concerned all you need to do
is say the word and you are the ISM that
is attached to that word but she she
went for the racism card because she
just couldn't help herself
she she she had to make it a race thing
it's compulsive she had to do it
couldn't control herself and so she
takes the L instead and here she is
finally officially taking the L watch go
back you know those types of words I
don't want to say he said go back to
your country or war back to where he
came from but he was making those types
of references is what I remember oh okay
okay well so so he didn't actually say
go back where you came from as in the
whole thing that made this story go
viral the whole source of her victimhood
claim all the racism ZUP are the thing
that made her that reduced her to tears
the thing that she was crying over
didn't happen now she says yeah well he
didn't really say go back where you came
from or go back to your country but now
now she says that he just said go back
and even if he said that much which it
seems like maybe he didn't even say that
I know you didn't really say go back you
just said go okay okay
he didn't really say go he said Oh which
rhymes with go which is the first word
in the phrase go back where you came
from that's but you know it's the same
thing but they didn't say we go back
where you come from you just said go
back if he did say that much it's pretty
clear now that he meant go back as in go
back to the appropriate checkout line so
she lied it seems very much so that she
that she lied what a shocking ending to
this tale utterly shocking shocking if
you've been lying in a coma in a cave
hundred feet under the ground for the
last 50 years and you just emerged into
the sunlight on Saturday then this is
shock and you'll be shocked by this but
of course if you have been a conscious
sentient being in this culture for the
last whatever amount of time then you
should not be shocked at all this is
totally expected what are the major
lessons here that we could take from
this I think there are three one and
these are all lessons that we already
know or should know one is yet again
don't believe stories like this without
evidence I mean it's so simple you you
hear one side of a story on social media
somebody complaining about something
that happened to them or an altercation
or something that somebody said whatever
you hear one side story there's no
evidence there's no reason to believe it
I mean there are dozens of reasons why a
liar might make something up on so it
happens all the time people lie on the
internet all the time I have news for
you all the time they do it for
political reasons they do it for
ideological reasons they do it because
they want attention they do it for
vengeance they do it I mean they do it
just to do it sometimes so sometimes
people lie because they're liars Liars
lie it's what they do so there are so
many reasons and I'm not and this isn't
just a left-right thing I think the left
is seems to be much more inclined to
making up these kinds of stories very
clearly but look it's the same thing I
mean sometimes you hear stories about
somebody will say oh I was out then you
know I was wearing my mag a hat and
somebody came up and yelled at me I
don't believe
those stories either unless unless
there's a video unless there's more than
something sometimes there is video of
these kinds of things happening but if I
just hear the story I'm not gonna
believe it immediately
oh he well he said it I think it
couldn't possibly be not true
uh if you hear stories like this and
believe them without evidence
you are either very very very stupid I
mean fantastically stupid amazingly
astronomically stupid or you're
disingenuous partisan hack and you know
that it might not be true but you're
running with the story anyway because
it's convenient for you those are the
two op or you might be both you might be
very stupid and a disingenuous partisan
hack which many disingenuous partisan
hacks are stupid I mean it could be both
or one of the but there's no other
there's no there's no option aside from
those two or a combination of them for
everyone who is not one of those things
you know we just have to wait doesn't
whatever the story is there's no
evidence there's no reason to believe it
in fact in general in life there's
there's there's no reason to believe
anything unless you have evidence and
what unless that there's no reason to
believe it unless there is a reason to
believe it unless someone presents you
with a reason to believe the thing
whatever it is you shouldn't believe it
doesn't mean that you should
automatically assume it's not true but
you shouldn't just believe it you should
be agnostic on the question whatever it
might be until you've been given reasons
to believe it that's the first lesson
the second lesson is that in this I
think it's a positive that look I'm not
saying racism doesn't exist in this
country we know racism exists we know it
exists among all races and that all
different races could be victims of it
but it appears that racism is relatively
rare in this country and I draw that
conclusion because you've got it's so
often now or you have people making up
racism claims where if racism was common
if it was an everyday occurrence as we
are led to believe then Erica Tama is a
justice Millette wouldn't need to make
it up they would have a whole
cornucopia whole buffet of racist of
racist interactions that they could
choose from there'd be no reason to make
it up right
Madhvi like bringing your own egg rolls
to a Chinese food buffet it's just
there's no reason you all the egg rolls
you want will be there so there would be
no reason to make up racism claims the
fact that that these people are making
up these claims kind of proves that well
they you know they want to be victims of
racism and unfortunately for them
society is not providing them those
opportunities and so they have to invent
it and then the third thing I think that
probably the most important lesson from
this everything else aside is if you
have more than 10 items stay out of the
express lane okay
period I don't care you got 11 items you
have ten and a half items I don't get I
don't care if the if the if the if the
item that takes you over ten is half of
a banana it's just whatever it is you
know one one grape from the produce
Island a section whatever it might be
you don't belong in the expressly okay
the express lane ten items or less
that's it our society the the proper
functioning of our society depends on
people following these rules I think
this is one of the reasons why I am very
worried and cynical about humanity's
chances of survival if there is some
sort of apocalyptic type event like an
asteroid strike zombie invasion whatever
I think we're screwed and the reason why
is because of grocery stores walk into a
grocery store any time and you see how
people if the rules are not being
strictly enforced at all times people
just ignore them I mean you've got
people goat using expressly when they
should be you've got people leaving
their grocery carts in the in in the
middle of the parking lot
you've got people you know touching
produce items and putting them back I
mean it's just people are you you've got
people like opening items to see is
there I don't
then they put a bag or you've got people
who take an item and then they go
throughout the grocery store and they
decide at some point oh I'd actually
don't want this and they put it back in
the wrong section it's the collapse of
civilization is happening at our grocery
stores people so I think this guy
apparently the full story is that this
guy he he saw I from what I from what I
gathered he had already been through and
but then he saw this woman abusing the
self the Express line and so he goes
back into the store to confront her yeah
he did not because he was being
inconvenienced but just because on the
principle of it and he confronts her on
it I think that's heroic I think he's a
hero we need more people to do that I
mean I'm at the point where I'll do that
with shopping carts in the parking lot
but I think this is what you know see
something say something I think needs to
be the approach from now on all right um
let's move on so from the saga of Erika
Thomas to the saga of Jessica
yaniv formerly Jonathan Yaniv he's the
the man who identifies as a woman and is
now trying to legally force a number of
salons in Canada to wax his genitals
yes that's if you haven't heard this
story that is that's the story that's
what's happening in Canada and he might
actually win his case his case is being
taken seriously up there in Canada where
apparently you know 75% of the people
have lost their ever loving minds and so
he might actually win this case just to
summarize Jessica yaniv decided to
identify as a woman at some point I now
as a as a as a lesbian in fact so he's a
biological male who likes women so he's
a straight guy in other words there's
another way of putting that but ever
since he transitioned transitioned in
quotes he has become bizarrely
determined to procure a Brazilian wax
and a Brazilian is is something a woman
gets done well I'm not gonna explain it
I you know you could look it up if you
don't know but the thing is these
bonds that do Brazilians most of them
are not they specific a Brazilian is
specifically a waxing of the female area
and that's what it is that's by
definition that's what it is so most of
the salons that do this that's what they
do they do this for what it is a service
for women and they're not going to do it
for men because that's they don't debt
they don't provide that service it's a
more delicate procedure as you could
probably imagine it's more dangerous
potentially so he's gone around to these
places to try to get the the waxing done
and he's been told that sorry we only do
that for women we can't we can't do it
for you it's not just that we don't want
to which that should be enough if if
you've got a woman saying look dude I
don't want to touch your junk that
should be enough we hear so much about
consent these days well consent I mean I
do not want to consent to touching your
genitals sir that should be enough but
on top of that they're also saying we
don't know how to do that we know we're
not trained in that okay do you really
want us we're telling you we we've never
done that for a guy you really want us
messing around down there so their case
against this guy is obviously just
airtight I mean this is totally clear
there is nothing there is not this guy
has no even shred of a point on his side
it's just completely clear that what he
that he is that this is that he's
totally in the wrong but he says
nonetheless that this is a violation of
his human rights and he's filed a human
rights complaint because we all have
apparently the human right the god-given
innate right which is inherent to our
nature as human beings to get Brazilian
waxes that's what he's saying and just
in making this claim he's already put a
number of women out of business or on
the verge of being out of business
because to defend themselves cost money
and they don't all have the money to
spend it most of these women are
immigrants too so he is targeting and
bankrupting immigrant women
this owners and doing so in an effort to
force them legally to touch his genitals
so let's just let's go over this again
this is a man targeting and ultimately
in some cases bankrupting immigrant
women business owners in an effort to
force them to touch his genitals this is
I mean if you're looking for misogyny
sexism rape culture any of that here it
is on a on a silver platter right here
for you served up this is a case of it
right here now this case has been in the
news for a while but up until this week
the identity of this guy has been
unknown but finally that information was
unsealed and it's being used in the in
the in the case at the whatever the
Human Rights Commission up there in
Canada so again with the least shocking
twist ever in history we find out that
Mister Yaniv is a degenerate creep and a
bigot he is just a vile disturbed
predatory person which we already knew
based on the fact they were trying to
illegally force women to touch his
genitals
so which is which is a form of legal
sexual assault that he's attempting so
we already knew that but it's even worse
than you imagined the post-millennial a
Canadian publication has done a deep
dive into the skies social media
postings and this stuff is very very
disturbing I'm gonna share some of it
with you just a a warning ahead of time
it's very disturbing graphic but I think
this man needs to be exposed not
literally but he needs to be exposed
what he's it's clear once you read his
what he's saying and what he has said
it's very clear that which again should
have already been clear that he really
wants a woman to touch his genitals not
because he really wants the waxing done
okay so let me read some of his facebook
posts some of his facebook post tweets
leaked text messages that he sent and
this
most of this is from the the
post-millennial we pull up some of these
okay so reading a couple here's one back
when he was Jonathan Yaniv here's a post
where he said how do I explain this
without getting banned on this group and
sounding like a racist we have a lot of
immigrants here who gawk and judge and
aren't exactly the cleanest people
they're also verbally and physically
abusive
that's one main reason why I joined a
girls gym because I don't want issues
with these people nor do I want anything
to do with them in any way they lie
about stuff they'll do anything to
support their own kind and make things
miserable for everyone else so here he
is complaining about immigrants calling
them dirty he's saying that he joined a
women a woman's gym in part because he
wants to avoid the dirty immigrants
that's what he says
here he is as Jessica Yaniv on Twitter
saying Twitter handle at trusted nerd by
the way in case you wanted I mean it
just in case you wanted to you know send
him a message or something and just let
him know how you feel about this case
you know whether you're pro or con just
maybe you want to give him a little
feedback I mean I don't know it's up to
you really but at trusted nerd so here
he is saying he's talking about
I guess he's advocating for some and
talking about a pool that he attends and
and he says I am requesting that we have
in all bodies swim here with allowances
for people aged 12 plus to go topless if
they wish as it's allowed in law so here
he is just advocating for topless 12
year olds at the pool yeah hey I mean
right no big deal right and this is a
guy who wants access and has access to
women's locker rooms and restrooms it
gets worse
okay there's some the post money all has
some leaked text messages where he's
going back and forth with somebody
[Music]
asking questions about what he might
experience in the girls restroom and he
has this and I won't even read all the
messages but there are several messages
which show that he had he has this this
fixation with girls on their periods
the possibility that he might have an
opportunity to help some of these girls
on their parents he says talking this
woman he says if she wants a tampon
though referring to a girl in the
restroom if she wants a tampon though
should I give her one and instruct her
on how to use it then he says later and
what would I tell her like would I go
into the stall with her and help her
later he goes back to this theme what if
she wants to know how to put a pad on
then what I know eventually I'm gonna
run into that scenario where someone
asks me to help at a different point he
asks if there's like 30 girls in the
change room how many of them would you
say are out there changing freely with
their genitals showing doesn't use
genitals he uses a more vulgar term at a
different point this now I'm quoting
from from a report of Daily Caller
he says if I notice a girl that's nude
below it has a tampon string coming out
when I'm changing and doing my stuff is
it weird to approach her to ask her for
a tampon or a pad just to bond with her
a bit over period stuff I really want to
make friends in there that's a kind of a
goal of mine okay and and and there are
many more you go to the post-millennial
or look this stuff up on Google there
are many more messages of this sort as I
said grotesque disgusting disturbing but
it's important for all I mean this guy
first of all he is he is going right now
we can go into a restroom or a locker
room with young girls making it very
clear that he is interested in in seeing
the sights in those areas I mean this
guy is a predator and he's didn't this
is the same man trying to force women
again legally to touch his generals try
to force them it's it's just it's
mind-boggling
I mean you I don't care how far left you
are I don't care how liberal I you could
be a pink haired feminist radical
pro-abortion volunteer Planned
Parenthood member of PETA I mean all of
vegan I don't care how far left you you
you have to see what's going on here I
mean you've got to see it if you have a
brain in your head if you are capable of
logical thinking at all you cannot
possibly take this guy's side and I
think that most people don't in fact I
am very confident that the vast majority
of people when they see a case like this
their reaction at least in their own
head to themselves is this is nuts
literally this is sorry this is crazy I
think that's the reaction most people
have but then a sizable chunk of those
people feel that they can't say it
publicly because they'll be castigated
as a bigot so they either have to
pretend that they're on his side or that
they see his point so to speak
sorry I can't they have to pretend that
they're that they're on a site or they
they they just remain silent but I guess
my message to everybody is listen again
no matter how liberal you are no matter
how progressive you want to seem no
matter how tolerant you are you know
that this is crazy you know that this
guy is a guy you know that you know it I
know it I know you know it you know that
I know you know it I mean so don't be
ashamed it's there's nothing shameful or
wrong with with understanding science
science is not shameful this is a matter
of science it's also a matter of common
freaking sense it's clear what this
guy's interested in he shouldn't have
access to locker rooms and bathrooms
alright last thing dina hashem let's do
a little comedy will lighten the mood a
little bit at the end
dina hashem is a comedian XXX 10
tascioni i guess as i abran how to
pronounce his name XXX 10th a song is a
dead rapper he was also a brutal violent
abuser who apparently beat his pregnant
girlfriend half to death
allegedly stabbed like seven or eight
other people and he was may shock you to
learn he was shot and robbed while
carrying 50 grand in cash several months
ago so he's dead now this is I guess
supposed to be some sort of tragedy that
this violent brutal abuser died he was a
violent man who met a violent end
just as Jesus predicted live by the
sword die by the sword live as an
abusive violent monster die at the hands
of abusive violent monsters that's kind
of how this works so when I I think was
like I said several months ago this guy
died when I heard he died I you know
well okay that's what happens to people
like that
I have to admit I didn't I didn't quite
shed a tear over it the fact that he was
abusive violent abuser who also wrapped
it doesn't make it any more tragic I
mean the fact that he could wrap does
not compensate for the monster you know
the the monstrous behavior that he
engaged in allegedly so that was my
thought anyway Dena Hashem made a joke
about this guy's death but the joke as
all jokes do now sparked controversy and
eventually it was apparently pulled from
a comedy saying this her set was
supposed to air on Comedy Central they
said they were gonna pull that joke
because people were offended by it so
let me play for you this very offensive
terrible joke that this comedian told
about the guy here's the joke is anyone
still mourning xxx 10s young
[Laughter]
he's a user rapper who was murdered he's
dead now he was he was shot he was on
his way to buy a car with $50,000 in
cash and somebody shot him and took the
money which is very tragic but I think
also it would be a very good venmo
commercial
[Laughter]
that's the first thing I thought
whatever they're like I don't know if n
mo I should get fen that okay that's the
joke and I think it's a clever joke it's
a good joke it's kind of morbid black
humor dark humor that I think dark humor
is not only okay not only acceptable but
necessary in a society you've got to be
able to tell jokes about it it's a sort
of common human instinct is to tell
jokes about tragic things you know death
in general is a tragic thing I'm not
sure that I would call a tragedy that
this particular guy given the lifestyle
that he led died but but regardless you
know is it's dark morbid humor and that
you need we need to be able to tell
those kinds of jokes I think it's
necessary that's it that's a service
that comedians provides important
service is finding the humor in things
that on the surface don't appear to be
funny at all that's their job it's what
they do and that's the really clever
comedians that's that that's how you
know if someone is oh is an especially
clever comedian is if they can find
situations that do not appear to be on
the surface funny now if it's a
situation that everyone can tell is
funny then it's you don't even need to
tell a joke about it because we all get
it but to find the thing that doesn't
seem funny and to find the humor in it
that's the whole gig as a comedian it
seems to me but people are offended now
by that because people are offended by
everything and this is why you just
can't you can't give the whiners and the
outraged mob an inch I think we have to
be at a point now we just completely
ignore them we don't care about your
feelings we don't care about your
perspective on this we just don't care I
mean you're offended I honestly don't
care at all
it just it does not matter I think that
has to be our message your feelings
don't matter about this they really do I
know we're raised it Oh am I feel how do
you dare you say my feelings don't
matter well they don't I mean a lot of
times your feelings don't matter their
feelings feelings can be
irrational they're often irrelevant they
don't matter to me why should I care
there that you could have feelings that
people should care about depending on
the situation right I mean if you suffer
the loss of a loved one and you're sad
about that
then we should care about those feelings
but in general every last little emotion
that pops in your head no we don't have
to care about that so when it comes to
this xx 10th estion he he wasn't your
loved one he's just a guy that wrapped
and apparently his loved ones he was in
habit of beating so if he wasn't loved
one of yours I doubt that you loved him
that much
certainly apparently didn't love you
that much so this is just just
ridiculous it was a it was a it was a
fine joke and I tell you something if if
dark humor if morbid humor is not
allowed anymore then Irish people are
especially screwed because that's the
only kind of humor we have you know if
you grow up around people of Irish
descent if you've been around Irish
visit all the all they talk about is
more is just death and suffering as
there's the whole source of comedy it's
a cultural thing so we're we're in
trouble I think in that case alright
let's go to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
alright this is from Teresa or Teresa I
think probably oh that's pronounced with
two S's
that'd be Teresa my name is Teresa and
I'm 11 years old
congratulations on your 300th show I
didn't even know I had my three hundred
years a bit three I've done 300 of these
things good lord what am i doing with my
life my dad listens to you all the time
I agree with you about spiders I think
they suck out your soul too can you
suggest any books about the faith that
are good for someone my age I asked a
priest but I I know and he said there
aren't any good ones my dad doesn't know
of any either
one more question my dad tells me one
day you will rule the world what age do
I need to be worried about your
impending rule and can I do anything
move myself from your wrath well Ted
well show you she signs it test so I
guess test would be all right test I was
I I will I will even though I will be a
brutal tyrannical lovingly tyrannical
dictator I will make an exception for
those under the age of let's say 16 so
as long as I come into power before you
hit your 16th birthday you'll be fine
anyway as far as the books about faith
your priest said he does that there you
you're free said there aren't any good
books about faith for someone your age
that is shocking there are many good
books about faith for someone your age
for people of all ages so let me let me
just one off the top of my head Fulton
sheen maybe you've heard a fault machine
he was a famous American bishop back in
the 50s and 60s and he wrote a book
about Jesus called the life of Christ
and he wrote a really long book it was
like 300 400 pages which I wouldn't
recommend probably for someone your age
might be a little bit too much you know
he might might be biting off a little
bit more than you could chew there but
he also wrote a shorter version of that
book much simpler shorter condensed but
90 pages just talking about Jesus his
life his what he did is you know the
Apostles kind of explaining the
significance of all these various things
in the Gospels and I would recommend
that one I think that someone you're I
think someone your age or someone of any
age who's able to read would would
appreciate that one
so life of Christ look that when I make
sure it's the night the one that's like
90 page is not the one that's 300 plus
this is from house I think I can't
pronounce that anyone's name today house
doctor house was that while I agree with
your sentiments about paying people
according to their merit the
discrepancies you laid out of 35 cents
per hour versus $35 per hours insipid
people even the inept ones need to feel
value and self-worth beyond cents on the
dollar well yeah I hear this a lot but
if you're saying that people need to
feel value and self-worth beyond cents
on the dollar
I agree that people need to feel value
in south where self-worth that goes
beyond the money the point of a job the
point your your employer's primary
concern is not to help with your
self-worth now they should still treat
you with dignity they should treat you
like a person I don't believe in slavery
or anything like that or you know
sweatshops for seven-year-olds but still
your employer's primary job is to run
its business it's not to help you with
your self-esteem or your self-worth you
shouldn't be looking for self-esteem and
self-worth in a job in the first place
although you know inevitably we all kind
of do that but that's I think we
shouldn't be we shouldn't be looking for
it there and regardless look this is
just it's just it's simple math as far
as I'm concerned you should be paid what
you are worth to your employer based on
the work you're doing you're not paid
based on your your worth as a human
because you're worth goes beyond money
okay we all work human beings we have
infinite value so we cannot be paid
infinity dollars so when it comes down
to it look it's you know some people are
paid 60 thousand a year some people are
paid 600 thousand a year it's not that
the person paid 60 thousand is worth
less as a person it's just in the
marketplace the labor that they do is
that's how much it's worth
it's a reflection of what they're doing
from 9:00 to 5:00 it's not a reflection
of them as a person so my point is that
if your attic sitting behind a register
and a Burger King or something and
you're just you have a terrible attitude
you're sullen and and and you know you
put in minimal effort you aren't worth
that much doing that job the work that
you're doing is so minimal so devoid of
effort so devoid of energy and
commitment you know you know and
positive attitude and all that that it's
just not worth that much and so my
argument is there are people steady mind
registered at Burger King who are worth
thirty five cents for what
what they're doing is worth 35 cents
because they're doing almost nothing and
so they should be paid almost something
there are others who are behind
registers at Burger King and other
places who are worth as thirty-five
dollars now possibly potentially because
their attitude is so good they're
putting in so much energy they make the
customer feel good they're putting a
smile on your face they're just putting
all of themself into this job even if it
is a kind of you know just even if even
if it is a just pushing buttons on
register so I think people should be
paid what they're worth for the work
they're doing last one from didn't get
the person's name probably for the best
I'm a 17 year old home schooler and have
not missed a single daily wire podcast
backstage or conversation since I
started watching in September 2017 my
dad is wondering why he got me
interested in politics in the first
place he started seeing warning signs
when he and I were able to have detailed
discussions on the policy positions of
almost every Republican presidential
candidate in the 2016 election that's
great I think you may be
misunderstanding the ontological
argument I have not researched
extensively but I think it may be saying
that the fact that we have the idea of
god whatever God that might be his proof
that God exists because I can imagine an
80 foot tall man with three heads but
that doesn't mean that such a thing
exists however where did I get the
concept for it height heads and and men
all exist so I can imagine a combination
of the above but from what you what
would you what would but from what would
you draw the concept of God and how many
individual people would have to do that
independently in order for so many
disconnected civilizations to
independently develop the concept of a
god I would put to you that we can't
imagine anything we don't already at
least in the back of our minds have a
grounding for in conclusion I would
state that we believe in God's because
we were made for the purpose of bringing
glory to God and how can we do that
without an instinctive knowledge of his
existence and yes that can be perverted
into the worship of false gods but where
would we have gotten the idea to worship
anything whatsoever in the first place
animals don't worship anything first of
all I mean said 17 has some had some
that's very impressive so you're
thinking through these issues very
cogent very coherent argument you laid
up
what I would say is a couple of things
first of all what you're talking about
there I don't think that is the
ontological argument the ontological
argument is an argument an attempt to
argue that God is logically necessary so
it's an argument in the vein of all
squares have four sides that is a
logically necessary statement it is it
is it is self-evident square by
definition has four sides or if I said
that all bachelors are unmarried it's
self-evident logically necessary because
if somebody is married then they're not
a bachelor anymore that's what an
argument of logical necessity is so
that's what the ontological argument is
trying to do is to prove that God is
logically necessary as I said on Friday
I respect the attempt I like the attempt
to try to prove that God is logically
necessary I think that's gonna be if you
can do it you're gonna have a much
stronger argument than the evidentiary
arguments where you're saying where
you're pointing the evidence and sango
fine-tuning or first cos or any of these
things and saying based on the existence
of this phenomena or thing it's it seems
like that would lead to the conclusion
that God exists those kinds of arguments
can be strong also but they're not gonna
be as strong as logical necessity
arguments my point though is I don't
think the ontological argument is
successful in proving that God is
logical necessity even if I believe that
God is a logical necessity I don't think
those arguments do the job improving
what you're talking about here is more
of an evidentiary argument where you're
pointing to the fact that people have
this concept of God and saying well that
would seem to indicate that there is a
God so I think it's a good argument but
it's not ontological it's it's it's an
evidentiary argument this is more if you
read CS Lewis I forget which book he
talks about there's probably multiple
books maybe mere christianity he talked
to he talks about the argument from
desire where he says that it's related
to you're not exactly the same thing
where he says that you know I have this
Iyer for a reality beyond this one have
a desire for a truth beyond above what I
see around me I have a desire for God
for an afterlife and it seems like if I
have a desire for something there must
be something out there that will satisfy
it and he makes the the point that that
we don't develop desires for things that
don't exist and I think that's true
so I think that's actually a little bit
of a stronger version of the argument
that you just made there because someone
could always say well you say well
you're not going to develop the idea of
something that doesn't exist I mean
that's arguable you know people I mean
my my my son six years old could sit
down and draw a monster or something and
just you're just something completely
out of his imagination and you could
always say that yeah well he's basing
that on things he's seen and so on but
it is it is something that is purely out
of his imagination something that
doesn't exist also but I think that I
think the the the stronger retort to
your argument is okay well maybe you're
right but most people I think everyone
our idea of God is based on what we see
we all kind of imagine God as a as a as
a as a guy as an old man with a white
beard sitting on a throne I mean even
even if we know that that's not what God
is when we're trying to imagine God
we're inevitably going to end up with
some kind of image like that or thinking
of God as a man as a you know as a as a
very old wise sort of man again we know
intellectually he's not that he's much
greater than that but when we're trying
to imagine him that's what we end up
with so I think someone could respond to
your argument by saying well okay maybe
you're right you're not going to have a
concept that doesn't exist every concept
has to be based on something that exists
but your concept of God is just based on
people around you based on your dad you
know based on whatever that could be the
response
your argument though is different I
think there's more to it there where we
do have the innate desire for God for a
reality beyond our own that is a very
strong desire and I think that's where
people or everyone develops their
concept of God even if the concept is
wrong or certainly incomplete which all
of our concept of God are it still is
what is pulling us in that direct
there's some there's a desire pulling us
in that direction what is that desire
and see us Lewis would say look you
can't you can't think of a desire that
exists for something that doesn't exist
you know we desire food we desire to
drink we desire sleep we desire all
these things we may desire things that
are wrong may desire things that are
simple but they all exist like no one's
ever developed a desire for a food that
just simply doesn't exist in on earth
right or for a desire to perform an
activity that is just that doesn't exist
anywhere so anyway I think that's a
version of the argument that is a little
bit stronger but the fact that you were
able to come up with that and sort of go
down that path on your own at 17 is very
impressive all right we'll leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
Godspeed hey everyone its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show at every
level of society people are being
silenced and controlled by corporate
leftists overseers that's why when Trump
speaks and acts without fear and
sometimes without thinking it sounds to
us like freedom that's what this
administration is about and that's what
the next election will be about - we'll
talk about it on the Andrew Klavan show